we know the importance of having a
healthy diet but we all have a sweet
tooth sometimes and can't resist the
temptation of eating gummies and there
are many reasons why they could be
better than real food stay tuned to see
why some gummies are better for vegans
than a normal meal love watching our
videos but looking for a more ad-free
browsing experience take your video
viewing to the next level and sign up
for the premium network you'll get the
first peek at the newest content from
not only the richest but Screen Rant the
taco the sports dearth of things and
many more thousands of your favorite
videos in one place is a no-brainer
click here to be the first in line for
the premium if you love fast food and
sugar as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 gummy foods that taste better than
real food hamburger most of us can't
keep ourselves from buying a big mac as
soon as we see the golden arches but
there is something that kids would love
even more than a happy meal it is the
gummy hamburger you might think that
nothing could compete with the real food
but listen to us there are many reasons
why you would preferred this mini candy
burger we know that most kids love sugar
if their parents weren't there to take
care of them they would just stick a
chocolate bar between two burger buns
and call it a meal and we know that they
need a lot of energy to have fun on the
playground moreover you don't have to
cook the gummy burger we don't want
children to hurt themselves trying to
make fast food and many grown-ups don't
like to waste time in the kitchen as
long as you can open the candy wrap and
put it in your mouth you have what it
takes to eat this delicious candy you
might think that the real burger is
healthier than the gummy one but there
are 520 calories in a Big Mac 28 grams
of fat and 950 milligrams of sodium if
we compare it to the candy it has 30
calories and is mostly made of sugar
with a little bit of protein so if you
are the kind of person who loves to eat
because you like the taste and not
because you are hungry the gummy burger
would be the best choice coca-cola every
hamburger lover needs a drink to satisfy
their thirst and we have to admit that
one of our favorite drinks is
this is why we were really happy to see
that they turned it into a candy okay it
might not be enough if we are really
thirsty but that's what water is for the
gummy will always taste better and if
you can't get enough of these tiny
sweets it is also possible to make a big
one all you need is a bottle of coke and
60 grams of unflavored gelatin mix the
drink of the gelatin in a saucepan on
the stove on low heat until it reaches a
gentle simmer carefully remove the label
on the bottle cut down the side of the
bottle tape it to avoid leaks and fill
it with liquid you just made let it
chill in the fridge overnight peel the
bottle add the label and there you go
your drink has been transformed into a
gummies and with this new texture we
think that it tastes way better it is
also much funnier to eat but which one
is healthier we will compare it to the
candy you can find in stores there are
140 calories and 45 milligrams of sugar
in a 12 ounce can it would take more
than 10 gummies to eat the same amount
of calories so for the next party with
your friends make sure you buy the
candies instead fries if you buy a
hamburger and a soft drink in any
fast-food restaurant they'll probably
ask you if you want fries too the answer
is yes but we don't want fries made out
of potatoes we want gummy fries but what
makes them so good what we love about
candies is that we can eat them anywhere
at any time we don't want to go to a
restaurant to find some all we have to
do is buy as many candies as we want and
carry them wherever we go we will always
be ready if we ever need a little snack
and because they are less smelly your
friends won't notice that you are eating
them and they won't ask for one but if
you really want it please them sharing
candies is always a good way to bond
with other people we know what is best
for our taste buds and our buddies but
what about what is good for our bodies
what makes the gummy fries healthier is
that there is less sodium in them and we
won't even compare to supersize fries
but to a mini fry the candy has only 70
calories and 10 milligrams of sodium if
you order some fries at McDonald's
you'll eat at least 120 calories and 90
milligrams of sodium your sweet tooth
will be happy to hear
that peaches enough with fast food some
of us like to eat something healthy too
and if you love sugar you probably know
that the best for your health is the
natural one you can find it in fruits
like peaches but there are many other
reasons why we can't stop eating the
candy our mouths love the taste but our
noses love the smell too as soon as
someone opens a bag of candy we can
recognize the smell and beg them for one
many people might think that eating a
peach at a party is boring but we all
know that gummy peaches are a must
moreover unlike fruits they will be good
for years to come if you buy a peach you
have less than a week to eat it and you
have to hope that it won't be crushed
into your lunch box but sour peach
gummies are invincible yes we know that
you have more chances of living for a
long time if you eat real peaches but if
you want to lose weight it is
technically better to eat one sour peach
than one normal peach it has only 19
calories while the fruit has around 65
we know that it is not important as you
will eat the whole bag of candies anyway
but if you ever feel guilty you can tell
yourself that the candy is not that bad
worms no one can argue with this one
gummy worms are better than real worms
you might think that it doesn't even
count as food but some people do eat it
it is an unusual meal but it is actually
a source of food for humans people in
almost 90 countries in Asia Africa and
Latin America eat insects and worms on a
regular basis there is nothing wrong
with that and many people think that it
tastes good but in America the only
reason why we would eat worms is if we
were lost in the forest for days with
nothing to satisfy our hunger some kids
tried to eat one because their friend
dared them to but almost everyone ate
the candy and you will be surprised to
know that this time the real food is
healthier than the gummy 100 grams of
mealworms might be worth 223 calories
but there are also good things in them
there are 20 grams of proteins and 2
grams of dietary fiber if we compare it
to the gummy there were actually fewer
calories 22 per worm but there are also
more carbs and sugar and less nutritious
elements and we don't think that it is
going to change your habits in any way
even if we say a lot of positive things
about
worms we think that the gummy ones will
stay the most popular in America
watermelon we can't enjoy summer without
eating a watermelon it is the perfect
fruit to stay hydrated and cool when the
weather is hot there is even a new trend
that we love turning the fruit into a
dress for a picture on Instagram but we
all know that watermelon gummies are the
best at any time of the year first they
don't make a mess when you eat it we all
know that when you try to cut or eat a
watermelon you end up with juice
everywhere we also need to take the time
to cut the fruit and we are really upset
when we realize that it is not good
anymore after a few days this is why we
love that gummies are always good and
ready to be eaten it can be difficult to
convince kids to eat fruits but when you
offer them candies you know that they
won't be able to resist and as we know
that the truth comes from children's
mouths we should believe them but
doesn't mean that it is good for their
health we are not sure about that sour
watermelon slices have 16 calories each
for 3 grams of sugar if you compare it
to the real watermelon there were 46
calories for one cup and it also is full
of water so the fruit wins when it comes
to what our bodies want but if we talk
about what our mouths want we know
gummies taste better
hotdog some people have a sweet tooth
and others crave salty foods and there
is something for everyone as a hot dog
is not only a meal anymore but also a
gummy --m our taste is explained by the
sensitivity of our taste buds if you are
less sensitive to sugar you will need
more to satisfy your cravings and this
is why you will eat more candies the
more we eat it the more we get used to
it and the more we need it and there is
another reason why people love sugar
more than they like salt when we eat
something like a hotdog gummy a signal
is sent to the reward center in our
brain so it could explain why candies
taste better than real hotdogs but have
you ever wondered which one is better
for your health we know that a salad
will always be the best choice but we
want to eat something that tastes better
a hotdog gummy has 30 calories 5
milligrams of sodium and 5 grams of
sugar if we compare it to an all beef
hotdog
it has 126 calories 10 grams of fat 23
milligrams of cholesterol and 464
milligrams of sodium
this is something we wish we didn't know
but there is no reason to keep ourselves
from eating only one or the other we can
have a real hot dog for lunch and
gummies for dessert breakfast this is
the most important meal of the day okay
this time we don't suggest that you eat
only gummy waffles bacon and eggs for
breakfast you really do need something
healthy to start the day but you know
what the most important thing in life is
it is being happy and the best way to
keep a smile on your face is by eating
candies the gummy breakfast does not
only taste better for anyone who has a
sweet tooth there are also many reasons
why you would prefer this treat if you
love eating fruits you will be happy to
hear that these gummies tastes just like
it the bacon tastes like cherry and
berry blast and the eggs taste like
lemon and berry blast the waffles taste
maple and lemon to keep the authenticity
of the breakfast moreover this gummy
encourages American workers it is
handmade in the United States for a
total of four hundred and forty five
grams of pure sweet love we don't know
how many calories there are in there but
there are probably a little too many and
you know what we don't have time to
regret anything and we will just enjoy
the gummies that might cost twelve
dollars which is more expensive than
your usual breakfast but we think that
it is worth it we know that it is
important to start the day with a smile
bears you might think that watermelon
tastes better in real life just like
fries or a hamburger but this time we
think that you will agree with us have
you ever eaten a bear the answer is
probably no gummy bears are way more
popular than the real animal it is so
rare to see people eating a bear that
you probably didn't even think that it
was possible but you never hesitated
when someone offered you some gummy
bears
you might feel bad for eating a cute
animal like this but do you know that
most gummies are not vegan if you look
at the ingredients you will often see
gelatin it is made by prolonged boiling
of skin cartilage and bones from animals
most of the stuff that is left over is
used to create that substance that you
can find in candies but don't worry you
can still eat bear even if you are vegan
many brands created gummy bears without
hurting any animal but if you are a
vegan on a diet you might be thinking
about your health too there are only ten
calories
gummybear and there are 46 calories for
every ounce of dairy meat you can eat
way more gummy bears than you can eat
real animals
every reason is good to eat more gummy
bears but if you need to escape one in
real life you might need to eat the
animal to have the proteins you need
Pizza
here comes our king the pizza anytime we
feel hungry we just have to call a
restaurant and someone will be there to
deliver it to our door in half an hour
we couldn't imagine life without pizza
and it wouldn't be as beautiful without
gummies this will be a tough competition
the candy doesn't require cooking and
can be eaten anywhere at any time
but it is also really comforting to have
a warm pizza in our mouth and eat it
with friends both are also a favourite
when it comes to taste and who wins when
it comes to health there are only ten
calories in a slice of gummy pizza so
this one might win if you are looking to
lose weight but if you want something
healthy real pizza could be a better
choice let's take the traditional
pepperoni pizza as an example there are
200 calories in one slice but there were
also many other things you need like
fibers vitamins calcium and iron this
time we don't think that we are going to
be able to choose between the two they
taste too good do you agree with any of
our choices if you prefer real food it
is time to tell us why in the comment
section down below we love to read what
you think may the best food win and
that's it for 10 gummy foods that taste
better than real food if you love food
as much as we do
don't forget to watch 20 kids cartoon
characters turned into cakes thanks for
watching
[Music]